around the time when I was still dealing
in The Mantel swamp there was a lot of
conversations because there was there
was a handful of gals that were in it
there was generally
heavily made up low-cut tops titties
pushed out selling how to get the gal
courses right so using flirty marketing
techniques uh to gullible persuadable
guys that thought that if they just
bought their course or followed their
whatever step program uh women would
start throwing themselves at them and of
course that would have never happened
um because that's what sirens do right
and when I collab with the guys in the
Mana swamp at the time
they all pretty much agreed that these
women don't offer a lot of value they
can't potentially be dangerous because
they mislead guys and they wouldn't
collab with them
they were for the most part ignored
um you know they were just thoughts that
sold courses on how to get the gals
right now
I think it was around late 2019 I might
be mistaken it might have been around
2020 but it's around 2019. I think
probably Myron was one of the first guys
to set up a podcast Studio where they
would sit down a bunch of gals at a
table so very Innovative totally
different
um it was a new thing I mean I've known
sorry I've known Myron for years prior
to that he was part of my community he
was one of my mentees I think overall
he's done wonderful for himself so
that's good and he and he carved out
this new genre where podcasting sitting
sitting down at a table a bunch of women
now that quickly evolved into entitled
bratty delusional usually drunk women
being used in this example and getting
schooled in front of camera which which
brought in a lot of eyes because that's
red meat
people like drama
they love chaos they like a train wreck
you drive down a highway and traffic
starts to slow down because your Waze
pops up accident up ahead and then sure
enough you get up there and there's a
[ __ ] train wreck on the side of the
road and everybody's got to go and look
at it even though it's off the side of
the road even the other lane coming the
other way not blocking no traffic block
also has to slow down to have a look
what happened over there that's that's
human nature they human nature loves
chaos it loves red meat so the sit-down
podcast Studio model was great for
capitalizing on that but if I'm being
honest it was a total clown show okay
but it does get a lot of views right
like it's it's it's chaos
it's it it's a lot of things anyway so
they had a whole bunch of success and
it's now one of the fastest growing
segments in the mantle swamp you'll now
start to see a lot more of these podcast
tables guests sitting around the table
usually with gals sitting at the table
and a so-called expert that's going to
guide you
through these spaces often using the
women as an example on the show
sometimes they're made to look quite bad
sometimes not so much but it's it's
dudes talking to dudes about
relationships using thirst traps in
podcast Studio to get men's attention is
what it boils down to it's all about
getting your eyes and women do that the
prettier the women the more eyes it'll
get from the beauty standpoint the more
chaos that ensues from bratty entitled
average sort of women the more rep you
know eyes you're going to get on the red
meat too now what was interesting was
the gals saw an opportunity to do the
very same thing swarms of them came in
created their own shows not looking to
help men and I'll tell you why I know
this because when you listen to the
conversations they're the exact same
talking points no innovation whatsoever
that have already been used by you know
your frame your favorite male craters
that have been around for a while or
have cooked up a lot of these ideas
nothing new it's like
I get these clips sent to me a lot of
the times from people please don't do
that I'm not interested in watching
thoughts talking about
um you know men's matters and I've of
course clicked through and I have to
watch them because I'm like okay what's
this and it's the same [ __ ] thing
like they're using the exact verbiage
that's already been used I might have
said it somebody else in the space might
have said it but it's just a
regurgitated uh message and they're not
there to help you with your struggles
they're there for the attention and the
money women have no idea what men
struggle with they they just don't they
it's nice when they pretend to know or
they pretend to care or they might
Express a little bit of empathy but at
the end of the day they truthfully don't
know and they really don't care I've
said this many times women don't give a
[ __ ] about your struggles a Hannah they
hang out at the finish line and they're
picking the winners that's what women
generally do there's some exceptions to
that but on a bounce of probabilities
that's how women typically behave
they're not King makers okay all these
women running around right now with the
raw I'm a queen queen boss girl boss
[ __ ] all that sort of stuff these these
women think that they're Queens they're
not King makers they're not sitting
around generally speaking waiting for
you to get your game sort out your life
if you're in your 20s maybe but if
you're an older gentleman in your 30s
maybe in your 40s or 50s they don't have
patience for that these women they want
to be with Kings they don't want to be
king makers okay that's the point of the
whole women way to the finish line and
they pick the winners that's essentially
what we're talking about anyway so these
so these gals they just want guys to get
it when it comes to life
now
if these gals that are pretending to
really care about men and their
struggles then they would organize
rather than just saying what's already
been said
not doing anything new or different with
it like they're not innovating with it
again then they would organize
themselves into tens of thousands March
down to a Capitol Hill Lobby changes on
hostile laws that you know are
pushing men out of the marriage
Marketplace because they're like why
should I expose myself to that risk I'll
date I'll go out with gals spin plates
whatever you know whatever dating
strategy they happen to build but a lot
of guys are like why get married there's
no advantage to it right it's it's all
risk with very low reward and it's the
opposite for her she's got very low risk
and very high reward so if if these gals
really cared about guys and their
struggles when it you know when it comes
to women that's what they would be doing
put on your pink [ __ ] hats march to
Capitol Hill get the laws changed that
destroy men with false DV charges
paternity fraud metus family law issues
all that kind of stuff right
as far as doing the work
gals can't tell guys to do the work
guys don't listen to their moms you know
guys who listen to their dads when their
dads say stop being a slob go to the gym
and lose some damn weight
right they'll listen to their old man
but their moms not so much they don't
listen to women with stuff like that
women have been telling their boys for
years now you're good enough son someday
a gal is going to come along and she's
gonna like you just for who you are
men tell their sons the truth right so
there's a big difference
regurgitating information on Tick Tock
YouTube Etc these are all social media
platforms and using experiences that men
have collected organized tested and been
sharing for thousands of years is more
profitable excuse me and make no mistake
a lot of the guys in this space and the
manow swamp they like to lay claim to
language verbiage ideas that they
created
I I have invented nothing here I have
just been paying attention to what's
been going on and I've just accumulated
this vast basket of knowledge and I now
share it with you I share with you
podcasts I've written the book for you
guys there's a follow-up coming up next
year
I guarantee
15 000 years ago there was men sitting
around a campfire maybe 20 feet from
where this house is built right now
and having a conversation amongst
themselves after a failed hunt or maybe
they lost you know 50 percent of their
men to some War you know the opposing
tribe and they sat there at the campfire
with no food empty stomachs realizing
they had to go back to the main camp
where all the families were and the
women and the children and they were
probably having a conversation along the
lines of these girls they don't care
about our struggles they're always going
to pick the winners why does so and so
get all the girls because he's the best
hunter because he's the one that kills
most of the opposing enemy I'm sure some
conversation like that happened 15 years
I did not invent that okay it's just an
observation it's a lot of the same thing
in the man of swamp a lot of the guys
that will be like well that's my
verbiage or that's my line or whatever
I can go back to the 1980s and there's
pickup artists like these these these
Pua guys that were on Oprah and other
shows like that uh making the exact same
statements that are made today you know
30 years later Ross Jeffries there's a
lot of guys in the space from you know
back in the day when they first started
making you know recordings of this and
there was a book
I remember this book A buddy of mine
ordered
um one of my roommates I think I was 27
or something like that and we'd go out
to the clubs and we'd have a good time
sort of thing
and at some point on the radio
um there was one of these uh dating Guru
guys who was talking on the radio
station about his new book that came out
I can't remember the title of it for the
life of me but we ended up nicknaming it
the Bible because it was like you gotta
copy the book and then we all read it
and we all sort of passed it around and
a lot of the same stuff that was in that
book is talked about today right so
there's not a lot of new ideas right
like um it's a form of nostalgia you
know for being honest I'll get into that
a little bit I got some other points
from uh from my other computer
um did you where was I tested been
sharing thousands of years it's
obviously very profitable it satiates
women's innate requirement for attention
and getting resources for men which is
what they do I mean you look at the
comments and these and these guys
these guys are literally simping for
these gals on social media
oh I'd love to find a girl like you oh
you just get it
you you guys think you guys think that
these chicks are going to be any
different in family law if they get
divorced you think that they're going to
be more patient for a guy that's running
a bunch of girls behind the scene then
you know the average they're not special
they're just they're just gals they're
all like all women are pretty much like
that right
um if they want to untie the knot and
family law is going to enrich them by
taking the kids away from the old man or
filing a false DV charge
it's entirely possible it's a tool in
the toolkit and they may use it against
you so don't think that they're better
than anybody else they're gals or gals
you know the women are all the women
sort of thing that's what guys like to
say I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out